taryn one of the things that you do on a
daily basis weekly basis to create
opportunities for yourself I create work
I mean I write screenplays so and most
of them have roles for me in them in
theory you know we'll see we'll see what
happens but but I think if you can and I
don't know I understand that maybe some
people aren't designed to create their
own work but maybe they could partner
with someone who's a writer who you know
maybe they don't have the discipline or
the ideas or whatever it is to to create
their own work but maybe they could
partner with someone who's very good and
needs actors in their work you know if
you're an actress you have a hard time
creating your own work but I right to
create opportunities for myself I have
been getting better about reaching out
to filmmakers I like about potentially
working with them and I need to do so
much more of that I like somebody
filmmakers I see so many indie movies
and there are so many wonderful people
doing great work out there but
yeah I think you just need to you know
think outside the box and while you
submit yourself for whatever you can or
you have an agent submit your you for
things that are going on I think it is
really important to try somehow to
create work because I I don't think I've
seldom seen someone hand someone else a
full career like you might get handed a
TV show you might get handed a couple
movies but I just don't know that it
sticks forever I don't know that I've
seen that I think eventually you create
one project for yourself you create a
couple you have some
control over that a lot of times that's
what I see
you